ja ich bin auch dankbar dass wir dieses
gespräch heute hatten dieses
ausführliche spricht dank vormachen die
kanzlerin die ja das inzwischen zur
chefsache gemacht hat das kann man heute
gemerkt gerade gegenüber der eu und den
ganzen partnern das ist glaube ich sehr
sehr wichtig in dieser doch zentralen
frage es trifft impfen trifft den nerv
unserer bevölkerung wenn es um corona
geht denn im plus die einzige echte
langzeitstrategie war
hinten macht große hoffnung hin führt
bislang aber zur verunsicherung zum teil
auch zu enttäuschen
das war das heute schon wichtig eine
ehrliche bestandsaufnahme zu machen
die klar macht dass wir das thema nicht
da und schlecht reden davon
wir sollten uns aber auch nicht
schönreden es bleibt eine der zentralen
herausforderungen der nächsten monate
die europäische union hat dargestellt
dass es ihrer sicht alles im plan
gelaufen ist
die wahrheit ist natürlich dass viele
menschen erkennen dass es große
unterschiede beim impfen in europa
vergleich zu anderen regionen der welt
gibt die kanzlerin hat es ja auch
dargestellt was die gründe dafür sind
die gründe sind natürlich da
trotzdem ist es für viele menschen
schwierig insbesondere dann wenn die
impfstoffproduktion dem nicht ganz
hinterherkommt und feststehende
impftermine abgesagt werden müssen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir soviel
planbar kreis wie möglich bekommen
deswegen ist wichtig auch die gemeinsame
plattform zu entwickeln wo wir uns
abstimmen
und wo wir versuchen da mehr ordnung und
struktur hinein zu bekommen was auch
klar ist im ersten quartal wird es nicht
mehr an den start
und das steht fest da wird also nicht
annähern im stoff kommen danach für die
weiteren quartale ist es so dass der
impfstoff ausweichen dürfte und zwar
weit ausreichen dürfte fakt ist eben die
frage dann nur der zeitachse die wir
dann haben andere länder und andere
region der welt könnten schneller kämpft
sein aber es hilft nichts sondern wir
müssen jetzt versuchen das beste zu
machen was auch sehr deutlich wurde
eine punktgenaue planung ist aus sicht
der unternehmen schwer möglich
quartalsmäßig ja wochentag war sie nicht
dafür seien zu viele variablen im spiel
variablen in der produktion aber auch
die variable mutation das muss man
einfach so sehen
deswegen werden wir nicht das sozusagen
mit
welche ohne stopp machen können sondern
werden an der stelle ein hohes maß an
flexibilität machen
das führt auch dazu dass die
kommunikation des erwartungsmanagement
anders laufen muss es vielleicht die
vergangenen wochen und vielleicht am
anfang den eindruck gemacht hat jetzt
ist das alles gelöst in drei vier wochen
ist alles vorbei man muss schon auf eine
lange zeitachse jedenfalls für das
nächste mindestens halbe jahr
diese entsprechend darstellen das wird
für die geduld der menschen noch eine
echte herausforderung
darüber dürfen wir uns nicht täuschen
und das ist auch sozusagen der
ernüchternde teil an der heutigen
besprechung
trotzdem ist es wichtig dass wir einfach
einmal die dinge übereinander legen und
nicht im nebel stochern und dann
hoffnungen aussprechen die nicht
erfüllbar sind also das wird eine große
herausforderung wir werden den rückstand
in anführungsstrichen gegenüber anderen
vielleicht nicht aufholen oder wir
können deutlich besser werden
im übrigen hilft es nichts eine ständig
erneute fehleranalyse jetzt muss man
sozusagen in den modus kommen
das gelingen und verbessern wollen es
wird auch noch mal wichtig seien die
prioritäten zu definieren
auch da hat der bund der
bundesgesundheitsminister zugesagt jetzt
nach astra zenica da auch noch einmal
für nächsten tagen für klarheit zu
sorgen bzw
im lauf der nächsten woche und ich würde
mir auch wünschen dass wir in den
nächsten wochen mehr impfstoff zur
verfügung steht das auch noch mal
diskutieren um auch andere jüngeren
lehrern und erziehern perspektiven zu
bieten denn dieses corona und auch das
impfen ist für alle wichtig es ist
zunächst mal für die risikogruppen ganz
entscheidend aber wir brauchen auch ein
angebot für jüngere für schule für kita
und da dann entsprechende mehr
möglichkeiten der freiräume zu haben
denn das ist ja was alle so betrifft
kroner ist eine echte herausforderung
für die gesundheit aber eine echte
stresstest für die nerven unserer
bevölkerung und deswegen muss auch klar
sein dass wir alles dafür tun in dem
bereich besser zu werden
zusammenfassend gesagt wir haben uns
jetzt heute sozusagen vorgenommen so
viel und so schnell wie möglich an
impfstoff mit den partnern zu
akquirieren wollen aber auch die
klarheit darüber haben dass es nicht
über nacht gehen kann und dass es auch
keine garantie gibt die unternehmen
haben zusagen für die quartale gemacht
aber eben keine hundertprozentige
garantie
das ist die wahrheit wie gesagt man
sollte sich nicht mehr dauernd schlecht
reden
man sollte daraus auch kein partei
praktisches spiel machen aber man muss
ich wahrheitsgemäß auch einfach mal
analysieren in der bestandsaufnahme
allerdings für mich an und ein klar
hätte es nicht diesen idee dazu gegeben
aber spürbar auch also soll man auch die
die klare führung in der frage wer das
jetzt viel und durchsichtiger insofern
noch mal danke schön denke dass schon
ein wichtiger beitrag um auch geistige
ordnung in das thema zu bringen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren